foreign
of five things that are really overrated
for me and I thought this was perfect
for this episode
because the first thing on that list
is books hmm we would talk a lot about
today about books and writing and
clinging to books and I think for much
of my life I overrated books
I want to be clear about what that is
and I'll talk about these other things I
think are overrated too but
I am all for reading I don't think
reading is overrated
but the physical artifact the book
itself I prized over the reading if I
have the book it makes me look smart if
I have the book it is the potential for
reading it has all the information but
of course
the information being a book is useless
to me if I actually if I don't read the
book right I would also say that in some
way books we
venerate them may be unnecessarily a lot
of bad books out there a lot of
unhelpful books out there
and we also force ourselves to finish
books that we dislike because
we don't understand the sunk cost
fallacy if I've already read 50 pages
and I guess I have to slog through the
rest of it well we're completionists
also yeah
you can't have a beginning without an
end it's yeah yeah I've totally have
done that before I'm like I'm already
halfway through it I gotta finish it
like maybe it'll get better if I keep
reading it's like yeah and and so I
think for me books and this is just for
me books have been overrated because
it's not that a book is more virtuous or
better than watching a series or playing
a board game I don't generally do either
one of those things
but I don't want to put books simply on
a pedestal I enjoy the act of reading
and whether that's a book or it is an
article from a magazine or it's a
quarterly review like the Paris review
which I'll hold up here this is going to
be on our added value segment later in
the episode I'm going to read my my
favorite poem to you it is
it's much more about the act of reading
itself than it is about the accumulation
of books so you really are one of those
folks who buys Playboy just for the
articles
laughs
you David Foster wall showed a really
great essay in Playboy Magazine back in
uh I think it was 95 96.
and um I never actually read it in
Playboy but it's in one of his books I
think it's in um it's called Big Red Sun
is the name of the essay I think it was
in uh considered the lobster anyway
um I in that case I would have yeah I'd
still look at the pictures though
uh all right couple a couple more things
that I've found to be overrated I've
always thought that flippers while
swimming totally overrated yes if you
agree with me let me know in the
comments if you disagree with me let me
know in the comments about any of these
as well I'm eager to know because
I remember as a kid I was I swam like a
fish as a kid but as soon as I put
flippers on hmm I just I was drowned
every time I did the same exact thing
man so yes the flippers that aren't made
specifically for swimming they're just
like aesthetic yeah um yes I totally
agree they're they are overrated I will
also say though that like Mariah and I
we went scuba diving
um on the Great Barrier Reef and the
flippers were extremely helpful like
underneath that water but but the thing
is is that like diving flippers they are
so long and they look so goofy like you
would never actually show up at a public
pool with these like because they make
you an extra two feet long you'd just be
taking up the whole hole exactly exactly
yeah so um but I do agree like the ones
that we got as kids it was just like it
was total it was total Aesthetics and um
yeah I said it almost probably killed us
more than it helped us
all right so good to know flippers for
the swimming pool bad flippers for scuba
diving good in your estimation yeah sure
yeah yeah
here's another thing I discovered to be
overrated recently Instagram the app
itself
um yeah I'm starting to get kind of sick
of it myself man and I spent over a week
off of it while I was gone and I
realized like oh that twitch
of what is going on I twitch for my DMs
for some reason which they're barely
even you know it's not like a hundred
people are messaging me a day it's like
a dozen so like it's not like you're
like who slid in today
and because it in it's essentially just
a text messaging thread at that point
yeah but then of course you get caught
up in all the other things it's like
when you go to the grocery store and all
of a sudden you're at the checkout aisle
and you start grabbing all these impulse
purchases Instagram is the impulse
purchase of the social media world
because as soon as we go to it for one
thing or we just go to our phone in
general if you have Instagram on your
phone you start oh I'm gonna go here ah
just for a second I'm gonna go here oh
what do they have to say oh I'm gonna
check her story real quick oh yeah what
about oh there's a message in my DMs
wait a minute 45 minutes has passed what
happened yeah what has happened I'm in
the Bermuda Triangle of social media I'm
careening from my DMs to the Instagram
reels to the Instagram photos to the
explore page and I just get stuck in
that Bermuda Triangle and so Instagram
can add value to people's lives I'm not
saying that it can but it is certainly
overrated for me and just spending one
week away from it
and I generally don't even have it on my
phone but I had it on my phone for a
while because we were posting these
reels and I didn't want to keep deleting
it every time but then I realized oh I
can actually post straight from a
desktop computer now as well that didn't
used to be a feature and so now I can do
that and I don't have to worry about
having the app on my phone it's much
calmer without it Professor shot Pro tip
uh you can create a script in your
browser to block the explore page so if
you click on it it's just blank oh no
search box nothing decluttering the
explore page do you guys ever do this
like
like the other day I was um expecting a
text message from someone so like I went
to go check my text messages but the
first thing I did is I was like oh to go
in I'll go to Instagram first and it's
just and then I'm like what am I doing
like I literally came here
to check my text messages and I've been
on Instagram for now 10 minutes and I
haven't even checked my text messages
yet right yeah and you forget why you
went to your phone in the first place
you went there for some reason yeah not
Instagram and then you ended up doing
something completely different than your
initial intention and so it's a
distraction and it prevents us from
doing the things that feel more
meaningful to us we were talking earlier
about sitting in the chair doing the
riding without distractions Instagram is
an easy way to distract yourself imagine
if every time instead of going to
Instagram
every time you just wrote a sentence hmm
how that would accumulate over the
course of one year or forget even
writing what if you just read a
paragraph you went to the Kindle app on
your phone and I did this initially when
I got rid of Instagram I replaced where
it was on my phone with the Kindle app
so
as I impulsed for the app I actually
would just open up kindle and I would oh
I'm already here I might as well read a
paragraph
yeah you can gain a lot of ground by the
way paragraph at a time that's that's a
thing that's underrated how far you can
go reading one paragraph at a time man
hey just the quick word about rating
usually when we talk about things being
overrated there are three categories
right there's overrated there's
underrated and then we rarely speak
about the third category which is I'll
say healthfully rated
um and I think it's easy for people to
hear overrated as a synonym for hated if
we say something is overrated that means
we hate it we think it's evil and you
shouldn't do it overrated just means you
know what there's some room for us to
extricate ourselves from this thing
there's some room to not play it up so
much to not praise it so much to not
venerate it as if it's some great and
holy thing and to say that something is
underrated isn't to say that it's the
best ever it's just hey there's some
room to appreciate that a little bit
more yeah and if something is
healthfully rated we mean like all
things it is good when we have a
relationship to it that moves us forward
in a constructive Manner and so when I
hear you say you know Instagram it's
overrated or you know things like owning
the physical copy of a book it's
overrated I don't hear it's a bad thing
and you should feel guilty if you value
it but rather
be open to the possibility that there's
room to venerate it a little bit less
yeah and there are so many things that
we can benefit from doing that kind of
exercise with looking at anything from
this coffee cup to this pen
you know is there room for me to
venerate it less is there room for me to
appreciate it more yeah yeah and this is
all perspectable too I mean it's you
know for for Josh's books um I find a
books very appropriately rated you know
right for you and it sounds like
flippers you also have them
appropriately there is a space for that
too yeah yeah yeah I have two more
things I'll just go through them real
quick vacations totally overrated for me
I don't like vacation I really like the
life that I have and so I don't feel the
need to escape it my life feels like a
Perpetual vacation in many ways and I
could not wait to get back and get to
work work feels like a vacation to me
too I was giddy when I started working
again but perhaps a vacation from that
is a pause enough to really feel giddy
about doing the work
finally one last overrated thing
freebies
um
yes Ryan and I back in our corporate
days we would entice potential customers
to show up at our store or at a table at
a booth Whatever by giving them a bunch
of free junk and essentially when I see
it now it's like whether it's like a
koozie that holds your beer or Coca-Cola
can whatever it is or it's a pen that is
worth about three cents or or a t-shirt
with the company's name on it oh it's
amazing like that was probably one of
the most popular things and at the time
I was like oh yeah of course it's free
clothes yeah but like hindsight I'm like
they really wanted to represent that
company didn't they yeah and I would be
free without it yeah and so maybe
there's the little play on words that I
don't need your slap bracelet I don't
need your PIN I don't need your Koozie I
don't need the corporate branded things
to complete me in fact they will
incomplete me they will only add the
excess clutter to my life your freebies
are not free because not only do they
take up space in my home but now I have
to do something with it you're now
burdening me so whenever I see the free
stuff now it's essentially like someone
saying here you get rid of this for me
and as soon as I realize that no thank
you I'll let it go in advance by not
picking it up did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free